hunting Trump destroying America that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
left has wanted to put Donald Trump in
jail since 2015. and today Democrats
have gotten them closer to that goal and
let's be very clear the White House is
the key player in this game of political
Vengeance now sure they're officially
saying no comment when they're asked
about Alvin Bragg's indictment of
President Trump
but make no mistake tonight Joe Biden
Bears the ultimate responsibility for
what this will do to America
you know our nation's chief executive
has the inherent duty to do everything
he or she can to preserve America's
standing in the world as the world's
leading democracy now that means whether
through back channels or public speeches
Biden should have made it very clear
that his party would oppose any local
prosecutor who uses trumped-up criminal
charges to punish and humiliate a former
president
but of course Biden didn't do this
instead once again he bowed to the far
left which has been salivating over the
prospect of trump and a mug shot for
years
a lot of Democrats spouting off saying
that they think Trump should go to jail
president Trump himself could end up
being prosecuted once he becomes a
civilian Donald Trump may have to go to
court and could possibly go to jail
people who know Donald Trump's conduct
have long said he belongs in jail he
could go to jail for up to four years
and tonight many on the left are
gloating you've read them on social
media and they're not considering though
what this is going to do to our country
tens of millions of Americans might be
half the country will come away from
this side Saga with less faith in our
justice system they're going to believe
that if you hold one set of political
views you'll be targeted but if you hold
another set of political views you'll be
protected
Americans will start believing that the
principle of equal justice under the law
is frankly a joke because they're going
to see the justice system is rigged
an America where prosecutors who wield
enormous power are just political hacks
Alvin Bragg is no different from any of
the hosts for instance on MSNBC
for them it's get Trump or go home
we all know that if Trump had quietly
retired from politics after the last
election he wouldn't be facing an
indictment tonight
he wouldn't be facing any investigation
in Georgia or by a special prosecutor in
D.C either
going forward when any American
president or Diplomat speaks out against
let's say the human civil rights abuses
in Russia or China
well those countries are just going to
respond with you're lecturing us nice
try but your system is morally bankrupt
you did everything you could to put one
of your own former presidents in prison
right before one of your so-called
elections
well and at that point given what's
happened who could argue with that
the fact is Democrats are doing what
we've watched tin pot dictatorships and
banana republics do throughout history
they made a political decision to try to
put their Chief political Nemesis in
jail
and they're indicting him in a state
where it's highly unlikely he'll ever
get a fair trial
now their case was such a loser that the
Department of Justice declined to take
it and the Federal Election Commission
didn't pursue it either
but now on the cusp of what will be a
fascinating perhaps competitive GOP
Primary 18 months before the
presidential election suddenly this case
is a priority on a state level
interesting timing
this is a shameful day in the history of
the country this is going to poison our
political landscape for years to come
and the entire episode makes Biden out
to be a total liar
so tonight those self-proclaimed
Defenders of democracy
they've been proven themselves Beyond
any reasonable doubt to be total frauds
in fact they've proven themselves to be
the ultimate election meddlers
pursuing a specious criminal case
against former president Trump for one
reason and one reason only because
they're worried that he might win again
now when Biden claimed that he was very
concerned about losing democracy in the
United States and that he was going to
protect it after the 2020 election he
was lying
all along he knew that the Democrat
machine would do everything everything
in its power Shady or not to keep a
populist conservative like Trump away
from the levers of power
after Biden was elected remember how he
said he told all the world leaders that
America is back
people thought this meant that he was
going to bring the country together
but that wasn't everyone what he was
intending instead he listened to the
French the far left who thinks Biden's
problem is that he's too nice
they needed to Pivot to being an
administration of Rage
where political opponents aren't just
Rivals they're enemies enemies to be
punished by any means necessary
now Biden could have made it clear to
Merit garland that they should be fair
to Republicans at the justice department
he could have insisted that the doj
enforced the laws against protesting at
the homes of Supreme Court Justices he
could have spoken out against
anti-christian hate and violence we see
that get seen it against churches and
pro-life Senators centers and he could
have said that if Trump decides to run
in 2024
I'll beat him the old-fashioned way I'll
beat him on the issues because America
doesn't jail political opponents
I can read Lincoln's second inaugural
address
now in the midst of an actual bloody
Civil War
now after that was his speech all about
vengeance
putting Robert E Lee and Jefferson Davis
in jail hell no
it was about how we as a nation needed
to come together
it was about reconciliation
now no one is saying that we should
ignore serious political crimes
but unless there's some bombshell here
that's been kept secret all this time
this case is an embarrassment of nothing
no one thinks Trump committed a real
crime here but ironically the people in
New York who do commit real crimes they
get off scot-free
courtesy of the Democrat Party and Alvin
Bragg
a healthy vibrant democracy doesn't jail
its political opponents
but the fact is the Biden Administration
has been a complete and utter failure on
every front
so they'd rather spend the next year and
a half sowing Division and hatred
than selling solutions to all the
problems that they created
they don't respect you they think you're
stupid
so they want to eliminate your options
at The Ballot Box by getting rid of
trump
the ultimate in election tampering isn't
it
and they want you and the angle so
distracted by this bogus criminal case
that we ignore the fact that the U.S
under Biden is spiraling down the drain
here are just a sampling of some of the
stories today that they don't want to
talk about
after transgender killed six at a
Christian School the White House said
they were praying for the trans
Community while Joe Biden said they are
part of the fabric of America
and at the border we just saw a group of
a thousand illegal immigrants Rush
across yesterday as DHS secretary
mayorkas claims he's unaware that the
cartels used situations like that to
distract border agents to bring in guns
drugs and criminals you name it they did
it
we have a reeling economy on multiple
fronts inflation persistent and the
banks are floundering
and at China's Direction the world is
quickly decoupling from the American
dollar
the ramifications will be devastating
for America if that continues
the Biden's approval on the economy what
is it 32 percent his overall approval
it's not that much better
heck only 25 percent of Democrats want
him to run again
so his conception of democracy is that
his family can make a fortune selling us
out to China and anyone who disagrees
with them will be subject to the Mob
intimidation or jail time
as of today tens of millions of our
fellow Americans will never be able to
see him as anything but a harsh selfish
partisan who only cares about keeping
his grip on power
every single Republican in office today
and tonight should be speaking out
against Bragg's persecution act I don't
care if you support Trump you're running
against Trump 2024 or not it's not
really about him in the end
tonight the man who is set to be his
chief rival in 2024 stepped up to the
plate Ron DeSantis releasing this
statement almost immediately reading in
part the weaponization of the legal
system to advance a political agenda
turns the rule of law on its head it's
un-American
Florida will not assist in the
extradition requests given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
the soros-backed Manhattan prosecutor in
its political agenda
perfect bingo
what is happening here should be a
warning to DeSantis or frankly anyone
else who may get within Striking
Distance of beating Biden
they should all realize that they'll
become a Target too
some prosecutors somewhere will allege
something
they fight dirty these so-called
champions of democracy
it's time for us to fight smart and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else